- [Joe] My dog's name is Bubbles.
- [Kelly] Bubbles.
- Yeah, and
she's very protective of Da-da.
- Oh, my dog Henry is like that.
- Yeah, she'll jump
at you.
- Okay, my.
- If you're near Da-da.
- Okay, mine doesn't do that.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
Mine just kind of growls.
- We'll keep a little distance.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- For right now.
- [Kelly] Keep a little distance.
- Just a little bit.
- [Kelly] Warm her up.
Get to know my voice.
- [Joe] Yeah.
- The rhythm of Kelly.
(Joe laughs lightly)
Well, let's get her comfortable
with the rhythm of Kelly.
Wait, which one does she
like more, you or Sophia?
- Me.
- I love that.
- Yeah, no question.
- It's like a big
giant dude with a little dog.
It's so great.
- She wanted the dog,
but the dog wanted me.
She was a rescue, so.
- Oh, I love that.
- You know, Sophia saw a picture of her
and was like, oh my gosh,
she is the cutest dog ever.
- [Kelly] She is.
- [Joe] So the shelter brought her over.
And as soon as she saw me,
she came running over.
(Kelly laughs)
And that was it.
And then she started
growling at Sophia to go away
and growling at the shelter people.
I'd never had a pet before.
- And you were like, we'll take her.
- I said, well, I never had a pet.
I said.
- You never had a pet?
- How do we do this?
Yeah.
- Not as a kid?
- No, and then I always
traveled and worked so much
that it was just, it was ridiculous.
I couldn't have a dog.
So the shelter brought her over and,
you know, she actually,
it turns out, was sick.
She was peeing blood.
- [Kelly] Oh no.
- And it turned out that she had a cyst
that they were worried might be cancer.
So, you know, Sophia was like, well, why
would they bring a sick dog
over without telling us?
And I just said, look,
you know, if they told us,
then nobody would ever have the dog over
and she'd never get adopted.
So I just turned to the
shelter people and said,
look, I'll take her, whatever happens.
- Look at that heart of yours.
- We'll figure it out.
(crowd clapping)
- That's so cool.
Because you have the means.
- I would encourage people.
Yeah, and that's the thing is like,
luckily she landed with
somebody who could,
you know, I could pay the medical bills
and whatever happened,
I was just gonna take
care of this little thing
and try to help.
And you know, I try to
encourage other people because,
during Covid, a lot of people
went to shelters and got pets.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then as soon as the clouds broke,
and we started going back to normalcy,
those people brought the pets back.
So there's a huge number
of pets that have been,
that have been brought back.
- Special place in hell.
- Seriously, seriously.
- The nerve to walk back in,
you walk back in.
- Imagine taking this little thing back,
I couldn't imagine, so.
- [Kelly] I mean, I guess
I'm glad they brought it back
into the shelter and didn't
just let it go, I guess.
- [Joe] Right.
- But dang.
- [Joe] Yeah, so people out there.
- I love animals more than humans.
- If you have the chance, like adopt,
adopt a pet if you can.
They're out there.
They need homes like more than ever now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.